oh my gosh chris it's the halloween show
i'm so excited yeah it's so fun so
let's go over the opening for two
seconds here so halloween because it's
like
you get to be anybody that you want to
be it's so awesome i know
what's happening where am i
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show
we're not in kansas anymore this is a
very
special halloween drew scarymore
right here in the land of oz
inspired by one of our all-time favorite
movies
the wizard of oz the definition of a
classic
we've got a wickedly good show and it's
full of surprises
i'm a good witch most of the time
but there are many other good witches
too
maybe even some in the vff's monique
ferguson hello hi
hello monique you
founded glamour diamonds dance academy
a non-profit dance studio serving
underprivileged kids
and you teach them and you tutor them
and you mentor them may i ask what
inspired you
to create this incredible program
well i've always had a genuine love for
youth
um primarily the less fortunate youth
and because i wanted to provide an
opportunity for
families that was in the situation that
i grew up in i found it more relatable
so i wanted to be able to i wanted them
to be able to
participate in an opportunity where
they can express themselves whether it
be by dance
music um my family when i was coming up
we didn't have the extra funds that was
needed in order for me to participate
so i wanted to make sure that i can
offer that to every youth that i came
in contact with and how do you think
that dance
inspires confidence in your students
well before i even teach them dance i
teach them
that they can conquer anything i
constantly remind my students that
they're number one
that they're important that they they
matter
so when my kids are in my program
they're not even allowed to say the word
can't in my presence
and i believe this pushes them to settle
for nothing less
than perfection so this also builds
their self-esteem which gives them
a level of confidence that screws over
into their
everyday living may i
ask how has it been going and
how are you able to keep this most
important
project alive um it's been a struggle
at times it's hard you know
being that 75 of the expenses that it
takes
to make this organization grow and to
continue
comes out of my personal pocket um and i
also quit my nine to five in order to
fully commit to this cause into this
organization
so at times it does get very difficult
but i am
definitely committed and no matter what
i'm i'm with the kids to the end it
seems like you bring
so much to their lives and you teach
them and you
show them and you give them faith and
hope and a place to go
and a place to go in their mind and
heart that they can
build their confidence and be
distracted with all of the right things
you are a good witch and thank you
i just want to say thank you and i'd
also like to contribute ten thousand
dollars
to put towards your incredible program
oh my god
get out of here true
[Laughter]
well thank you so much monique you might
why don't you cry on tv
don't do that i feel like crying too
because you know what we got to keep
taking care of each other
and we have to keep important programs
like yours going
and we have to support each other and i
know that's what we're here
on this beautiful round bubble to do
is to have each other's backs and to
lift each other up
and carry us along in this big beautiful
life
so oh my god you're a good wish too
most of the time i'm inspired by people
like you monique
thank you so much for all that you do
may we check back in with you
and see how things are going with you
and your girls
absolutely anytime we'll be checking in
on you and your munchkins very soon
thank you